[Música]
ya sabéis que a pesar de ser humorista
voy a hacer una charla seria para mí es
muy difícil
22 de diciembre se lo digo a todos os
suena la fecha verdad que ocurre el 22
de diciembre no puede tocar el gordo de
navidad no me refiero a este gordo baret
sino a 100 décimos dotados con 400 mil
euros cada uno cuatrocientos mil euros
lo que rodrigo rato-- llama una noche
loca
así que todos o casi todos los españoles
llevamos un décimo verdad y muchas veces
lo tenemos compartidos con amigos con
familiares así que imaginarnos a
nosotros a mis chicos ya mi el 22 de
diciembre de 2017 cuando de pronto en
pleno sorteo navidad aún no se sabía
cuál era el gordo y nos suena el
teléfono y yo pensando dios que sea
alguien para decirnos que nos ha tocado
y mi chico contestó y se puso blanco
blanco blanco blanco y pensé
seguro que es mi cuñado para decir que
la toca oa él
pero no
era nuestro pero neuropediatra el
nuestro no es de nuestra hija pequeña
emma para decirnos que ya tenía los
resultados de una prueba genética que
habían hecho y tenía un síndrome el
síndrome de cena materna
toque deciros que fue el peor día de
nuestra vida
perdona
[Aplausos]
gracias solo lloro cuando hablo de emma
o cuando me denuncian por lo penal
mucho más lo segundo
fue muy duro que tu hija tenga un
síndrome raro y más como este es un
millón de veces más malo que no te toque
el gordo de navidad porque tienes todas
las cifras menos la última que tu hija
tenga síndrome de la materna es casi tan
malo como que le toque el gordo al
de tu cuñado
y estábamos destrozados de verdad que si
estamos destrozados el 22 de diciembre
2017 pero un año después el 22 de
diciembre de 2018 nos dimos cuenta
viendo esos 12 meses que en realidad
habíamos tenido mucha suerte y el 22 de
diciembre 2017 nos había tocado el gordo
tranquilos que sé que esto es una charla
de decks no voy a empezar aquí con la
motivación ni lo guay que es tener un
hijo con una enfermedad rara mis
operaciones personales os voy a contar
por qué decimos que con emma y sufren
amateur me nos ha tocado el gordo
el pelo matter min es una enfermedad que
afecta al cromosoma 22 en el brazo largo
en su parte 13 y por eso también se la
llama de lección 22 13
y afecta a un gen el sant 3 el sant 3
produce las proteínas que hace que haya
fijación en las neuronas cuando hay
schinasi neuronal es decir que
aprendamos que haya conocimiento gracias
al sant 3
nosotros podemos aprender y cuando no
hay sanz 3 pues las personas aprenden
poco como mi hermana al casarse con mi
cuñado
y eso es lo que pasa es que sus
proteínas no funcionan bien y no puede
aprender como le pasa a todos estos
niños pero decimos que hemos tenido
mucha suerte porque el síndrome de
feldman dermis sobre todo se caracteriza
por dos cosas porque tienen trastorno
del espectro autista y porque tiene en
ausencia del lenguaje nos dijeron que
nuestra hija probablemente nunca podría
comunicarse con nosotros nunca podría
hablar cosa que todos los que tenéis
hijos sabréis que a veces es una ventaja
quiero decir bendita adolescencia no los
iba a poder llevar nunca la contraria
pero decimos que hemos tenido mucha
suerte por tres motivos el primero por
su de elección una dirección es cuando
te falta un trocito de adn y además
falta ese trocito de adn en el gen 22
y qué es lo que pasa que te puede faltar
trocitos de diferentes tamaños en españa
por ejemplo la persona que tiene una
mayor afectación madre diagnosticada con
fer amateur me tiene una falta de 9,2
megas de material por encima de 9 a 8
megas los niños nacidos nada más nacer
mueren o mueren intraútero es decir son
abortos esta es una prueba vale de
diferentes tamaños de erección de niños
en españa la de arriba en 9,2 la de
abajo del todo en nuestra hija
004 satinada dirección pequeñísima la
elección de mis es casi tan pequeña como
el cerebro de mi cuña
y además está bien situada qué quiere
decir eso en la mayoría de síndromes en
casi todos cuanto mayor es en la de
elección más afectados están pero en el
seno medio de efe la ma término pasa eso
en el síndrome de fernando almíbar
imaginaos el brazo largo en el sector 13
que es donde está situado pared el
amateur milles así de grande vale pues
un niño que tenga de aquí aquí 5 gb de
perros a 5 mb de pérdida de material
genético y otro niño que la tenga aquí
imaginaos un mega
5 mb un mega el que tiene una pérdida de
un mega puede estar infinitamente peor
que el que tiene 5 porque esto todo esto
es el sant 3 pero además aquí hay otros
genes cuya de elección toca y hace que
los niños estén mucho más afectados y la
de manos él es pequeñita sino que además
está muy bien situada sólo toca al gen
shank3 y además es el mosaico eso
significa que de las células afectadas
solamente el 66 por ciento de sus
células tienen fe la materna tiene un 34
por ciento de células sanas
para que entendáis qué es esto cuántos
de vosotros levantan la mano conocéis o
habéis visto en la tele alguna vez a una
persona con síndrome de down que se
puede hablar perfectamente no parece que
tenga discapacidad intelectual incluso
ir a la universidad y un actor muy
famoso todos lo recordáis probablemente
esas personas lo que tienen es un
síndrome de dawn en mosaico es decir la
enfermedad el síndrome está poco
activado y como se traduce eso una
dirección que sea pequeña bien situada y
el mosaico pues que de todas las cosas
que puede tener el phenom a término
discapacidad cognitiva la ausencia del
lenguaje el trastorno de espectro
autista hipotonía hay niños que no
aprenden ni a sentarse nunca van en
silla de ruedas tiene un crecimiento
acelerado retardados tiene
malformaciones en riñón en cerebro
incluso pueden tener neurofibromatosis
epilepsia a día de hoy nuestra hija solo
ha tenido un trastorno de espectro
autista
una ausencia del lenguaje tiene una
pequeña una pequeña malformación en los
riñones que no es significativa y tiene
las cosas típicas del phenom a terme
físicas que muchas veces pasan
desapercibidas es muy alta
tiene los ojitos un poquito achinados un
poquito separados un poquito créditos
tiene los párpados un poquito hinchado
en la frente un poquito ancha tiene la
nariz un poquito baja y regordeta aquí
así un pelín ancha y está tiene la
frente muy llenas no sé si lo he hecho
pero tienen manos grandes y carnosas y
las uñas de los pies un poquito
quebradiza porque os digo esto o parece
feo ese niño
diríais que ese niño tiene un síndrome
genético pues esa es la putada del fe la
materna que la mayoría de niños como no
tienen ningún rasgo tos con nada
peculiar nunca se suele pensar que
tengan algo más allá de un trastorno del
espectro autista de hecho os presento a
hugo
a marc
a beatriz ya mi hija emma
si se nota por el limón que es de murcia
y porque no se le entiende a la web
y por qué os digo esto porque esta
charla me gustaría que todo lo que
estáis aquí y todo lo que la estén
viendo en un futuro nos ayuden a
diagnosticar a los niños y a las
personas con phelan materna por lo que
os digo porque son cosas muy sutiles si
en algún momento alguien tiene o conoce
a alguien con trastorno del espectro
autista que vea si tiene alguna de las
cosas que hemos dicho hasta ahora
y por qué es importante diagnosticar
sabéis en qué media de edad se
diagnostica en españa este síndrome
entre los 6 y los 7 años
y aquí viene la segunda do motivo por el
que digo que nos tocó el gordo de la
lotería
somos de murcia
porque digo esto pues muy sencillo
porque pues no sabéis que la sanidad las
competencias cada comunidad autónoma
aplica las suyas propias
y en murcia fijaos este es el plano de
españa cortesía de julián nevado que es
el jefe del responsable de genética del
hospital la paz que está haciendo el
ensayo el estudio de la materia en
españa y estos son los casos
diagnosticados cataluña 15 casos 8
millones y medio de habitantes
perdón 78 millones de habitantes 7
millones de habitantes armesti lidiando
con andalucía y cataluña discúlpame es
que soy de murcia
y andalucía nueve casos comunidad
valenciana- sois unos cinco millones de
habitantes catorce casos murcia millón y
medio de habitantes quince casos
casi nada es que diré lo mismo porque os
canséis entre primos pero no
bueno a veces sí
es porque la comunidad autónoma de
murcia es la única la única comunidad
autónoma de este país que aplica los
estándares de calidad si tú tienes un
niño con un autismo y algo más por
ejemplo una ausencia del lenguaje
tienes que mandarle una raid por si
acaso por si acaso pero no se manda en
el resto del sitio porque son pruebas
caras de hecho veis que hay 49 casos en
madrid
muchos de ellos diagnosticados porque es
donde se está haciendo el estudio el fel
amateur mis padres que consideran que
sus hijos tienen algo y en sus
comunidades autónomas no les hacen la
prueba se le hace gracias a la
asociación de celama terminen españa en
el hospital la paz
casi nada y diréis esto para qué sirve
pues muy sencillo porque si tú ya sabes
qué es lo que tiene tu hijo las terapias
que le dais le des estarán encaminadas a
lo que tiene y serán más efectivas y es
lo que nos pasó a nosotros
a nosotros nos pasó eso nosotros
teníamos una niña que tenía unos
movimientos muy repetitivos que jugaba
repetitivamente con las cosas que no
hablaba que no nos miraba que tenía
rabietas impresionantes y la llevamos a
un servicio de neuropediatría y primero
nos la diagnóstico de trastorno de
espectro autista a los 16 meses de edad
pero cuando llegaron las pruebas
genéticas unos tres meses después a los
19 meses de edad ya era un gel amateur
mí lo cual quiere decir que las terapias
que le dimos en atención temprana
estuvieron encaminadas a su fe la
materna y aquí viene el tercer motivo
por el que digo que hemos tenido mucha
suerte tenemos dinero
no me refiero tenemos dinero para
intentar deshacernos de ella
si no tenemos dinero para pagar las
terapias de atención temprana porque
aunque no lo creáis si volvemos a lo
mismo que cada comunidad autónoma tiene
su propia sanidad en españa las terapias
de atención temprana no están dentro de
la cartera de servicios comunes del
sistema nacional de salud así que cada
comunidad autónoma hace lo que quiere
esto es españa madrid por ejemplo tienes
hasta dos años de lista de espera para
que a tu hijo la atiendan por lo cual
necesita dinero durante esos dos años
para pagarle terapias privadas andalucía
el tiempo de espera bien son gratuitas
sí pero tengo 45 minutos a la semana
casi nada si tú eres un niño con
parálisis cerebral y necesita logopedia
necesita fisioterapia necesita más cosas
pues hace yo que sé diez minutos con
cada uno un popurrit por lo cual sigue
necesitando dinero para pagarlas
murcia tiene poquita lista de espera y
las terapias te dan todo lo que tú
necesites o si es de copago sigue
necesitando dinero para pagar las
canarias no hay ni atención temprana
siempre van con retraso
de hecho este miércoles se aprobó la ley
y supongo que entrará en vigor dentro de
unos días ley por cierto que si hay
alguien de canarias aquí o hay algún
canario o canarias viendo esto en un
futuro ley que no se ha hecho gracias a
partidos políticos sino que se ha hecho
gracias a un grupo de padres y
profesionales de la atención temprana
así que yo si fuera canaria y me
encontrase en algún momento por la calle
yo que sé pues con jj o anna le estaría
dando besos hasta reventar porque
gracias a ellos son niños van a tener
terapia
y diréis vosotros bueno pero para que
todo este rollo que nos está soltando
pues por dos motivos muy importantes
primer motivo porque me gustaría que nos
ayuda a 6 a que otra gente tuviera la
suerte que hemos tenido nosotros porque
me ha tenido una elección pequeñita que
eso no lo podemos controlar pero sí que
se puede controlar que haya un
diagnóstico temprano y sí que se puede
controlar que las terapias sean
gratuitas para todos cosa que ahora
mismo no es y por qué es importante
diagnosticar y diréis bueno y qué más da
un trastorno especialista en flama termi
porque estos son todos los médicos que
tiene que visitar una persona con fela
matter min en el mismo día en que es
diagnosticada creo que quitando
gerontología pasa por todos
y luego por un segundo motivo porque me
gustaría que todos los que estáis aquí y
todos los que nos vean en un futuro
además de ayudarnos a diagnosticar el
fel amateur me entre todas las personas
porque aproximadamente un 1% de las
personas con autismo tiene flama térmica
en españa hay unos 150 diagnosticados se
cree que son 4000 además queremos que
nos ayudéis con la atención temprana
queremos que nos ayudéis a reclamar que
sea gratuita y accesible en todos los
puntos de españa y sin límite de tiempo
y con todo lo que se necesita porque es
muy sencillo porque sé ahora mismo
vigilan de quitar el gordo de navidad
creo que saldremos todos a la calle a
colmar contenedores
y mirar que hay una posibilidad de uno
entre 100.000 de que nos toque el gordo
de navidad estábamos hablando intangible
y el gordo de navidad piaf intangible no
te va a tocar
pero en cambio la atención temprana hay
una posibilidad de uno de cada diez uno
de cada diez niños que nacen en españa
van a necesitar o necesitan atención
temprana porque por muchos motivos
porque la ciencia danza y los niños que
antes eran sabes se morían nada más
nacer pues ahora conseguimos que vivan
porque ahora sacamos adelante a los
prematuros y los prematuros si están por
debajo de las 32 semanas tienen que ir a
atención temprana aunque en principio en
principio nos vayan con ningún tipo de
problema ya hayan salido adelante bien
porque hoy en día se diagnostica mucho
más se diagnostica más a los niños con
trastornos hiperactividad con trastorno
de espectro autista
hoy en día se dan terapias donde antes
no se daban acordados como como se hacía
antes con los niños de síndrome de dawn
hace 40 años y cómo se hace hoy en día a
las personas que tiene con síndrome de
edad se dan terapias desde el principio
terapias para desarrollar su máxima
capacidad entonces tengo que recordar
que 1 de cada 10 niños en españa
necesita atención temprana y que en casi
todos los puntos de españa dependen del
dinero de sus padres
y para que veáis el rollo que os estoy
contando de por qué hemos tenido tanta
suerte
cuando digo por esa elección pequeña
bien situada y en mosaico porque hemos
nacido en murcia y fue un diagnóstico
temprano y porque tuvimos dinero para
pagar la atención o presentó a emma
i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o la valencia a la defensa o la charla
terex
cómo te llamas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
se lo que estaréis pensando esa
pronunciación es por el suelo mater mis
buenos recordar que la niña murciana
muchas gracias valencia
[Aplausos]